اتعلمين على مستوى الجوده نحاول ان نعمل
مع الماركات المسجله الكبرى كقيمه مضافه
ولكن المفارقه هي ان
سكان سلطمي لا يعلمون مدى هذه الجوده
وربما هذه
المفارقه
حيث في كوكبنا هنالك من لديهم
موارد طبيعيه
بالامكان تحويلها ولكنها لم نتشارك في هذه
الخيرات
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم ناخذكم في هذه الحلقه
الى دوله افريقيه تقع في خليج غينيا على
خط الاستواء جمهوريه ساوتومي وبرنسيبي
وتعني حرفيا القديس توماس والامير جزيره
صغيره لا تتجاوز ربما الف كيلو متر مربع
يعيش عليها قربه 200 الف نسمه تعد ثاني
اصغر بلدان القاره الافريقيه استعمرها
البرتغاليون لفتره تزيد عن 500 سنه
موقعها المتميز في خليجي غينيا قباله
الساحل الاستوائي الغربي افريقيا جعل منها
قبل نحو سته قرون احد اهم مراكز نقل
العبيد نعم نقل العبيد من القاره السمراء
الى اوروبا على يد المستعمر البرتغالي
الذي ظل فيها اكثر من 500 سنه تركيباتها
الثقافيه المتنوعه سمحت لها بتقديم نموذج
فريد في
الثقافات الافريقيه والاوروبيه وتعد
جمهوريه
مستقره سياسيا رغم محاوله الانقلاب التي
تعرضت لها وهي ثلاث محاولات انقلاب منذ
1990 كيف هي اذا الحياه في سوتومي بمختلف
مناحيها سؤال عريض خير من يجيب عليه هو
رئيس وزرائها باتريس ايميري
انا خديجه بن قرنه وهذه حكايه جديده من
بودكاست الجزيره بعد امس اهلا وسهلا بك
سيد سيد
دولتكم دوله معروفه في العالم بانتاج
الكاكاو ذو الجوده العاليه بانتاج القهوه
ايضا ذات الجوده العاليه معروفه بانها صوت
ايضا لها دوله لها صوت لها مقعد في الامم
المتحده في الاتحاد الافريقي والمنظمات
الدوليه لكن لو حاولنا ان نعرف جمهوريه
ساوتومي للمشاهد العربي ماذا يمكن ان تقول
لنا
نحن دوله صغيره نحن اصغر ثاني دوله بعد
اسسال هي مجموعه جزر
ولكن
بما اننا لا نختار موقعنا
الجغرافي حتى يفهم الناس اين نتواجد
نحن تقريبا
نبعد ساعتين على صوت مي
ونحن قريبون جدا من القاره الافريقيه
تقريبا ساعه واربعين دقيقه عنا انجولا
وكذلك عن سحل العاج
ونحن قريبين كذلك من افريقيا الوسطى حيث
يتواجد 400 مليون ساكن في تلك المنطقه وهي
منطقه لديها كذلك مخزون اقتصادي كبير
وقرابه 200 الف ساكن فقط في جمهورياتنا
سالتني كيف اصف بلدي هي جزيره الشوكولاته
حيث
ننتج الكاكاو
نريد ان نكون دوله منفتحه دوله صديقه
للجميع دوله
سكان مع علاقات جيده مع الطبيعه ومع مناخ
الاعمال تلك هي الرؤيه هي ان نكون بلد
منفتح وبلد
يمكنه التعامل التجاري وربط علاقات جيده
مع الجيران وهي الدول ثريه ومهمه جدا في
القاره الافريقيه ونحن مقتنعون
الشوكولاته او الشوكولا ربما الناس التي
تشاهدنا لا تعرف انه الشوكولا الراقيه جدا
في سويسرا في بلجيكا مثل غويفا وغيرها من
الانواع هي بالاساس مصنعه من الكاكاو الذي
ياتي من بلادكم
اتعلمين على مستوى الجوده نحاول ان نعمل
مع الماركات المسجله الكبرى كقيمه مضافه
ولكن المفارقه هي ان
سكان لا يعلمون مدى هذه الجوده
وربما هذه المفارقه
حيث وفي كوكبنا هنالك من لديهم
موارد طبيعيه
بالامكان تحويلها ولكنها لن تشارك في هذه
الخيرات لا ياكل الشوكولاته او لا تصله
الشوكولاته بالشكل المصنع في بلجيكا
وسويسرا لانه الوضع الاقتصادي ليس جيدا
ولكن هناك امال هناك افاق هناك اكتشافات
للبترول في المياه في البحر اهلك ان
تحدثنا عن الاتفاقيات الموقعه مع شركه شيل
العالميه
والاكتشافات البتروليه في دوله نعم
[موسيقى]
لدينا العديد من الاكتشافات البتروليه
وبدانا برنامج منذ بضعه سنوات واليوم مع
شركات نحن متفائلون جدا
بالامكانيات المتاحه
من اجل
تشغيل بعض الابار شركه شال تقوم
بالاكتشافات والنتائج مثمره
ونامل ان نتحقق من الامكانيه التجاريه وما
هو مهم بالنسبه
لاي
مسؤول سياسي هو خاصه سعاده المواطنين
الكاكاو هو مورد والبترول كذلك هو مورد
ولكن لا يجب ان ننطلق بفكره الاستهلاك
ولكن ان نعرف ان نحدد مع
جوده الحياه والرفاهه والسعاده اللازمه
وعندما تنظرين وانا ادعوك لزياره صوت ان
شاء الله حتى تطلع على جمال الطبيعه وعلى
جوده الحياه لا يوجد هنالك ازدحام
للسيارات
وحركه النقل وهنالك كذلك مساله الامان اذا
ما نريد هو ان
نتغلب على الفقر المتقاع ذلك ودفنا الاول
الموارد سواء كان بترول او سياحه او زراعه
او الصيد البحري ولكن يجب ان نضع صوب
اعيننا سعاده الشعب
سعاده الناس في صوت ان تعيش في ازدهار ان
تعيش
ان تكون يعني حياه حياه سهله لكن ليس هذا
هو الحال في صوت لانه هناك اعداد كبيره من
الشباب
الذي يهاجر الى دول مثل البرتغال اذا كيف
نفهم هذه المفارقه كيف يمكن اعتقد ان هذا
هو اكبر تحدي بالنسبه لك انت كرئيس وزراء
مواجهه هذه الهجره للشباب السوتومي الى
اوروبا اليس كذلك
اعتقد ان اي شخص يتمنى العيش في بلده بكل
تاكيد ونحن اليوم مجتمع منفتح سوتومي هي
ديمقراطيه بها حركه التنقل وهو بلد شاب
لدينا لحسن الحظ التواصل عن طريق الانترنت
ولدينا
مستوى
علمي
بحدود سته سنوات جامعيه تقريبا بالمقارنه
مع جيرلن الافارقه
ولدينا اكثر من خط
هاتف نق لكل شخص يعني ان التواصل الرقمي
متواجد
وعندما يدخل الشباب على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هم يطلعون على العالم ولدهم
طموحات ولديهم احلام واذا ما قدمت لهم
فرصه داخل البلد فمن العادي ان يحاولوا
المغامره بالخارج ولحسن الحظ نحن
تفوضنا وحصلنا على اتفاقيه مع البرتغال من
اجل الهجره الامنه وهي ليست بذلك مغامره
غير محسوبه اذا هي هجره مؤطره بتاشيره
وهو سلاح ذو حدين من ناحيه هنالك الامانه
في الهجره وليس المغامره مثل ما يحصل في
اللجنه غير الشرعيه في بحر متوسط ولكن هي
في نفس الوقت قوه حيه من البلد تهاجر
وتغادر علينا ان نحاول ان نعكس هذا التيار
وان نخلق الفرص في الوطن حتى يبقى هذا
الشباب لاننا نحب وطنا نريد ان يقول لك
والناس تهاجر تحديدا الى البرتغال
نعم
لاننا نتكلم اللغه البرتغاليه
والبرتغال يقدم تاشيره الى البرتغال وليس
التاشيره الى اوروبا
بسبب
الاتفاقيه التي
تجمعنا وخاصه القاسم المشترك وهو اللغه
وهو مثال ايجابي
لاننا مستعمره برتغاليه قديمه
تحصلنا
عبر النضال المسلح للاستقلال وبعد ذلك بعد
تمكنا
الانضمام الى
المستعمرات القديمه
البرتغال وبطبيعه الحال هناك اعتراض
بالخطا ثم تصالح ربما الناس لا تعرف تاريخ
استقلال
بعد 500 سنه من الاستعمار البرتغالي وهي
حركه نضاليه قاده حزب امل وكان قد استلهم
هذه التجربه النضاليه من
الثوره الجزائريه وايضا ايام الرئيس
الاسبق هو ريبو مدين اليس كذلك
نعم
تم استعمارنا طيله 500 سنه من البرتغال
وفي السنوات الستين
حيث كان هنالك
الطموح للانعتاق من الاستعمار الفرنسي
والانجليزي وغيره
وما كانت تسمى بمستعمرات برتغاليه
المطالبه بالاستقلال البرتغاليون لم
ينصطوننا بالاذن الجيده لذلك انخرطنا في
النضال المسلح
كذلك على مساعده الدول ومسانده الدول
الافريقيه
وكان هنالك
افارقه اكثر تقدما مثل الجزائر التي دفعت
بالتضحيه والدماء استقلالها والجزائر كانت
من اول الدول التي
ساندتنا وسعادتنا
وكذلك
العاهل الراحل
جلاله الملك محمد الخامس الذي سندنا
وكذلك تلقينا المساعده من كل الدول
الافريقيه والتضامن من هذه القاره خاصه
الدول
المستقله حديثا
وكنا في فتره الحرب
البارده لذلك الكتله الشرقيه
السوفييتيه ساندتنا كذلك في فتره
الاستقلال واريد ان اؤكد
اننا خاصه
ندين
للرئيس الراحل هواري بومدين حيث وقعنا
اتفاقيه الاستقلال في الجزائر
سنه 90 بدا الوضع يتغير بدات محاولات
الانقلاب محاوله اولى محاوله ثانيه ثم
محاوله ثالثه امام محاولات الانقلاب هذه
كيف يمكن تفسير صمود التجربه الديمقراطيه
في امام كل هذه المحاولات
في بدايه استقلالنا
تقريبا من حزب واحد
ولكن بعد 15 سنه
كان هنالك
التعدديه
وبدانا نفكر في طرق مختلفه
للتنميه وذهبنا الى التعدديه الحزبيه
وهذا الانطلاق نحو الاستقلال تخللت هو بعض
الاضطرابات
التي مثلما سميت بها محاولات انقلاب والتي
لم تاتي اكلها لان الشعور الديمقراطي كان
اقوى
ونعتبر انها كانت محاولات هامشيه
والتي تم التغلب عليها بطريقه سلميه
وبامكاننا ان نعتبر ج
مستقره حيث هنالك انتخابات تقبل فيها
النتائج بكل الاحزاب بدون اي اعتراض وانت
رئيس وزراء هذه الدوله الصغيره في افريقيا
واجهتكم تحديات اقتصاديه كثيره منها جائحه
كورونا اقتصاد البلاد الان منذ جائحه
كورونا بدا يشهد نوع من التراجع ماذا
المستمر الى الان التراجع الاقتصادي
التضخم الديون كيف واجهتومي وسايتومي
وبرانسيبي هذه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه
التي ما زالت تعيش الى الان
اعتقد ان
المشاكل الاقتصاديه كانت دائما حاضره
فترات افضل وفترات حالكه
وعندما يتم انتخابك
لم يجبرك احد على الترشح
بل الشعب امام بقدرتك وعليك ان
كرسي السياسات
التي تعتبرها افضل لشعبك ولبلدك
واعتقد ادهم مساله حوكمه مساله شجاعه
سياسيه كذلك
ويجب
محاولات المزج بين الشجاعه والتواصل مع من
انتخبوك
فعلا نحن نعيش وضعات تضخم
تضخم له جذور واسباب ونحاول اتخاذ
الاجراءات اللازمه
تتعلق
وهي وساده
حد من الصدمات هنا نسبه الديون هي 300
مليون دولار والدين الخارجي
بالنسبه للدين الخارجي هو دين كبير
وبالطبع لا يتم
الاقراض للاغنياء وعندما تكون دوله فقيره
فانه من الصعب الحصول على القروض ورفع
الديون المشكله ليست التدين
بل هي القدره على دفع الدين اليابان
والولايات المتحده دول ثريه ولكنها تعاني
من ديون كبيره اذا هي مساله حوكبه يجب ان
نتحكم في جوده الدين للخروج من الوضع
الرهن
ونحن ننظر الى ذلك بكل سكينه وهدوء ونعتقد
انه علينا استقطاب الاستثمار الخارجي يجب
ان يكون هنالك مناخه مناسب للاستثمار
وان نتداين فقط من اجل الامور الضروريه
مثل البنيه التحتيه
الطرقات
والمطارات وكذلك قطاع الصحه بالنسبه
للبقيه نعتقد انه علينا ان نطلب من الشعب
ان يقوم بجهود مثل ما تفعل الحكومه وكل ما
يتعلق
بالادويه لا يدفع عنها ضرائب او جمارك
وكذلك المواد الصحيه
نقوم بجهد على مستوى الضرائب حتى لا تتاثر
الطبقات الادنى
واعلى المستوى الدولي من
يقبضوننا
نحاول ان نتحلى
بالشفافيه حتى يعلم كيف استغلاته اعذرني
على المقاطعه الدول التي تقرضكم
مليا وربما هذا يعني احد اسباب وجودكم
اليوم في الدوحه ومساله جلب الاستثمارات
تتعملون مع من هي اكثر الدول التي تتعاطى
معكم في مجال الاستثمار والاقراض ايضا في
البدايه اقول ان
قروضنا هي متعدده الدول مثل البنك
الافريقي
وكذلك
البنك العربي الافريقي
وبالنسبه للاستثمارات المباشره لدينا خاصه
الاوروبيون الذين يستثمرون لانهم يعرفون
افضل بلدنا والمنطقه مع ذلك نحن ننظر في
اتجاهات اخرى خاصه دول الخليج اولا
تعتقد ان لديهم رؤيه متميزه في الاستثمار
وهي الدول تمكنت من
استقطاب افضل جدوى على مستوى البناء
التحتيه والاستثمار والخدمات الماليه
والاستشارات
في هذا المجال ونحاول ان نستغل هذه الخبره
وهي الدول لديها
صناديق سياده مهمه وهي موجهه
المردوديه ونريد ان نساعدهم في اكتشاف
الدول الافريقيه
والدولنا خاصه ان الاستثمار الخارجي في
افريقيا
يتعلق
بمشاريع مردوديهاتها
تكون بنسبه 23 و 25% لذلك نحاول ان يكون
ذلك مثمرا بالنسبه هنالك مخاطر
وبعض
القطاعات
تستحق هذا الاستثمار اذا نهايه
الاستثمارات المتعدده
الاقطاب والتي تتاثر من اوروبا خاصه نحاول
ان نعرف
بدولتنا في اتجاهات اخرى حتى الاهتمام
المغرب
ليبيا
قبل تغير النظام وتونس
وكذلك مصر
التي هي دول من القاره الافريقيه ولكن نحن
منفتحون في اتجاه دول الخليج
ونعتقد
ايليا ان لدينا العديد من النقاط المشتركه
بطبيعه الحال افريقيا الشرقيه ربما هي
معروفه اكثر لدى الخليج بسبب
العلاقات بحكم
زنجبار واليمن والعلاقات التاريخيه
التجاريه القديمه ولكن
المجال في منطقه المحيط وكذلك مثير
للاهتمام ندوه العربيه لدينا موارد مثل
الغاز
والنفط
وعلى مستواه كذلك الاسمده
التي تمكن الدول الخليج من ان تستثمر هاته
الموارد
واغلب كذلك الاراضي الصالحه للزراعه
متواجده في القاره الافريقيه وفي منطقتنا
وهنا
بامكاننا ان تكون لدينا صفقات رابحه
للجانبين مع الدول العربيه
لدينا اراضي صالحه للزراعه التي تحتاج
ربما للاستثمار ولتكنولوجيا
وادوى العربيه وليست فقط لديهم هذه
الامكانيات يجب ان نعرف بانفسنا افضل
وان نتمكن على مستوى العلاقات
البنكيه ان اعتقد هنا الكويت لها تجربه
معكم في الاستثمار
بدانا بالاستثمار الكويتي في
ونحن لدينا قروض
بفوائد مفضله ولكنها بدايه جيده
ونحن نثني على هذه الخطوه الاولى من قبل
دوله الكويت ونامل ان تكون هنالك
خطى اخرى ومهوى
مهم هو خاصه ان نخلق مناخ الثقه تعلمين ان
افريقيا
في بعض الاحيان تعاني من قله الاستقرار
وكذلك من الارهاب في منطقه الساحل
الافريقي
وكذلك مساله الانقلابات العسكريه يجب اذا
ان نحل هذه الاشكالات وفي نفس الوقت ذلك
لا يمنع ان المستثمرين
في افريقيا
يتمكنون من مناخه الثقه
واليوم عندما نتحدث عن التكنولوجيا
الصناعيه فان اغلب
الموارد الرئيسيه تتواجد في افريقيا
وهذه القدره الاستثماريه
العربيه على غرار دوله قطر الناجحه يجب
كذلك ان
يكونوا شركاء ولاعبين اساسيين في افريقيا
التي لا يمكن ان نتجاهلها طيب هذا على
مستوى
الاقتصادي والاستثمار على المستوى السياسي
سيد رئيس وزراء
انت تعرف انه القضيه المركزيه للعرب هي
القضيه الفلسطينيه
وبالتاكيد انت تتابع كل ما يجري في
الاتحاد
الافريقي من جدل من لغط من صراع حول موضوع
ادخال او دخول اسرائيل كعضو مراقب في
الاتحاد الافريقي اين انتم من هذا الجدل
حسنا
شخصيا اعتقد
ان محاوله اسرائيل ان تصبح عضوا
مراقبا
ومحاوله
اقناع
يجب ان تتم بالمواجهه وبامكاننا ان نعتبر
بانه علينا ان نجلس على نفس المائده مع
اسرائيل
ونتناقش في هذه المسائل
يجب ان نعرف ما هي النوايا من ذلك
انت تعلمين كلنا كبرنا ونشانا
بمبادئ الحريه والاستقلال كلنا
ترعرعنه على
حس ابو عمار
السيد الراحل ياسر عرفات ومع القضيه
الفلسطينيه ولا يمكن ان نقبل السياسه ذات
المكيالين لا يمكن ان نقبل بالاعتداء
اذا عفوا على المقاطعه مره اخرى اذا افهم
من كلامك انكم ضد دخول اسرائيل كعضو مراقب
في الاتحاد الافريقي
نحن لا نعارض ذلك مباشره ولكن يجب على
الاتحاد الافريقي ان يتخذ مواقف واضحه
بالنسبه لهذا الوضع
كعضو ملاحظه ربما
ولكن لا يمكن
لكن العكس يحدث مثلا مع جنوب افريقيا هناك
سفاره لاسرائيل في جنوب افريقيا ولكنها ضد
دخول اسرائيل كعدو مراقب في الاتحاد
الافريقي تماما عكس الكلام الذي تقوله نعم
نحن نحترم
موقف جنوب افريقيا
وجمهوريه سوتومي وبنسي
نحن دائما نناسب الحوار
ويجب الجلوس على نفس الطاوله لحل
الاشكالات
وهذه الامكانيات
او ربما هذا الطلب من قبل اسرائيل
لا يمكن ان نصد امامها الابواب ذلك لا
يعني اننا نفتح الباب على مصراعيه لان ما
يحصل من استيطان
على الشعب الفلسطيني المحتل نعم ولكن انتم
صوت في الاتحاد الافريقي انتم مقعد وصوت
في الاتحاد الافريقي وقراركم يؤثر طبعا
تصوتون لي مع ضد يعني مهم ان نعرف موقفنا
المبدئي
ما كان
هنالك اي تصرف يدعون الى معاقبه اسرائيل
سنعاقبها
هنالك العديد من الدول المنضويه تحت
المنظمه
[موسيقى]
الامميه ومن يخالف ذلك يعاقب اذن ليس
لدينا اي معارضه ان يكون هنالك اي بلد
مراقب ولكن هذا الموقف
مرتبط كذلك بمساله انانادد عندما يكون
هناك موقف يستحق التنديد واليوم اسرائيل
لديها حكومه تتخذ مواقف معينه ربما لو تم
اختيار حكومه اخرى مختلفه
بمواقف متسقه اكثر مع المبادئ
ولكن بالنسبه لنا ليس اعتراض على هذا
المبدا
[موسيقى]
سيد رئيس وزراء
تتحدث عن القاره الافريقيه على انها هي
دعنا نقول سله غذاء العالم في المستقبل
بها الثروات بها موارد وهناك اطماع هناك
اطماع من القوى الكبرى في العالم
لوضع اليد على هذه القاره الافريقيه الان
امام هذا التنافس الدولي اين تتوقعون اين
تتموضعون هناك صراع روسي هناك صراع
روسي فرنسي امريكي صيني على القاره
الافريقيه حسنا الامر كان دائما كذلك
يجب ان ننظر اين توجد مصالحنا
سواء تعلق الامر بالروسيين او بالصينيين
او بالغرب او بالامريكيين واريد ان افرق
بين الامريكيين والاوروبيين
الجميع لديه مصالح
والمهم بالنسبه لنا كفارقه
هو ان ندافع على مصالحنا
وكذلك ان ندافع عن شرعيتنا
التي
تعتمد على الشان الداخل وليس الخارجي وقد
ان تخبط حتى احل مشاكل الصحه والتعليم
والبطاله والبنيه التحتيه وغيرها لذلك انا
اعمل صالح هذا الشعب هنالك مواقف مبدئيه
نحن دوله صغيره
ولا يمكن نؤمن لا يمكن ان نخالف مبدا عدم
التدخل
الاراضي الدول
لكن تقليديا وتاريخيا
كانت تسبح في فلك الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا
اليوم اين تجدون انفسكم في المعسكر الشرقي
ام الغربي عندما
تطلبين من شعبي اين تتواجد اوكرانيا او
جورجيا او كازاخستان
فهم دائما تتعلق افكارهم بالاتحاد
السوفياتي
اذا
نحن
نفهم
ربما بعض اسباب
التي تتعلل بها روسيا خاصه الطوق طوق
الحلف الاطلسي المضروبه على روسيا ولكن
بخصوص المبدا لا يمكن ان نحل
المشاكل باجتياح دوله اخرى صحيح لكن سؤالي
ليس هذا سؤالي هو الان هناك انسحاب
فرنسي مثلا من عدد من الدول الافريقيه
روسيا تملا الفراغ في بعض هذه الدول انتم
كيف ترون هذا التنافس الدوري على افريقيا
ان نستغل هذا الجانب ولكن ما لا اجده
عاديا
هو ان تقول
لا اريد الاستعمار الفرنسي ثم تنتمي الى
العلم الروسي
اذا نحن لدينا مبدا عدم الانتماء للمصلحه
الخارجيه لا يمكن ان تعوض الفرنسيين
بالروسيين وهو امر متناقض لذلك انا لا
ادافع على هذا المبدا المليون على سبيل
المثال عليهم تظاهر بالعلم
ساناديك هذه المره بالسيد حبيب وليست
روفوادا وربما اكشف سرا للمشاهدين
والمتابعين انه لديك اسم اخر وهو اسم
حبيبه هذه قصه اخرى نريد ان نتطفل عليك
قليلا لتروي لنا قصه حبيب انا
من دوله
99% منهم مسيحيون
ولكن
ووالدي كذلك
مسيحيين
ولكنه لم
بل تركوا لنا الحريه الدينيه
ولم يتم تعميدي في الكنيسه
وبطبيعه الحال انا من الجيل الذي ولد بعد
ان يضال ضد الاستعمار
البرتغالي
لم اجد نفسي في الديانه
المسيحيه وفي قراءات اهتممت بامبراطوريه
العثمانيه التي بالنسبه لي
كانت ربما
المعادله
لرفض الاستعمار المسيحي
واكتشفت بهذه القراءات الدين الاسلامي
ووجدت في
الاسلام خاصه انه لا توجد مساله الرهبانيه
وان تكون في علاقه مباشره مع القران
الكريم وجدت ذلك كشكل ميناء الحريه
وبقراءه القران الكريم
وبالممارسه الدينيه
اكتشفت هذه
الحريه سبحان الله
اخترت ان
اعطنق الاسلام قمت ذلك بطريقه سريه لان في
تلك الفتره والدي كان رئيس الدوله
واردت ان لا اخلق اي صدام وبطبيعه الحال
الاسلام هو المعرفه وهو النقاء وذهبت
سافرت الى
وكنت ابن رئيس الدوله وتم استقبالي من قبل
نائب الرئيس الايراني رفسجاني
وقد درس في
باريس وكان سفرا مثير للاهتمام وعندما
عدت الى بلدي
سال السفير الامريكي من هو هذا حبيبه
في اي سنه
في سنه 1984
[موسيقى]
كم نسبه المسلمين في
نسبه قليله جدا من المسلمين ولكن هنالك
زياده في عدد المسلمين
وانا
كمسلم وكرئيس
وزراء
اتشارك في هذا الشعور مع اخرين وهنالك
منظمات
تتصل بنحن دوله
محايده
جدا
واعتبر ان هنالك اسلام واحد ونحن
[موسيقى]
قد نتعاون مع دول اخرى
لمساعده
من
يعتنق
الاسلام وهو نوع من الجهاد يقوم به
جهه جميل شكرا جزيلا لك السيد بكريس
على هذا الحوار الجميل وانت رئيس وزراء
سوتومي وبرانسي بي شكرا لك
مشاهدينا كان هذا بعد امس لكم منا اطيب
المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]